Hulk versus Iron Man and Johannesburg so
great Tony debuts the mark 44 Hulkbuster
powered by seven additional Arc reactors
notice how Tony's heads up display zooms
out to convey the extra layer but Tony
slips up you're stronger than her you're
smarter than her you're Bruce spanner I
don't mention puny banner and when they
call Hulk Banner he rages but when they
call him Hulk or big guy he cooperates
Tony goes for a KO let's go sleep go to
sleep go to sleep remember Pander did
sleep through Tony's story in Iron Man 3
and after this Banner will stay asleep
for years Polk spits out a tooth just
like Abomination did and gets real
pissed he swaps away Veronica's back up
Tech back at her to destroy both Tony
has to drop a building on him and around
a year ago some viewers spotted that
Tony safely implodes the building with
rockets hitting it from the side showing
how his past collateral damage has
affected him and setting up his feelings
on the sokovia chords it ends with Hulk
getting punched out of frame calling
back his great hit on Thor in Avengers
foreign
[Music]